before we say goodbye we like to play a
quick roundup truth or dare
all right
all right in our audience we have
brittany leslie hypertones oh how are
you guys i love that youtube it's
brittany and not brilliant yes all right
so what's it gonna be a truth or a dare
it's a truth all right what is it i have
a horrible habit of never putting away
my clean laundry
i want to know what is one bad habit
they're each trying to break
okay you know when you you know when you
open your phone and you see like how
many emails you have left to return
mine is over uh 90 000
of unread emails and so
i know that's how i feel every morning
that i look at it i'm my uh new year's
resolution two years ago was to respond
to every single email that i ever got
i did not do that
so this year i'm gonna break that habit
that's a habit i gotta break i think you
should refresh and delete and start from
the beginning so you have a chance of
success okay maybe i'll do that instead
okay thank you
um okay i am having an epiphany in my
life right now
that the critical voice is something
that i would like to avoid everything i
say to myself the way i talk to myself
is so critical
so i'm having this critical voice
epiphany where i'm wanting to stop it
and i'm gonna squander that you know
what like nobody's business for once in
my freaking life
because
it's so not neat thank you brittany
[Music]
you